plein qu'en dise monsieur blanc caire
monsieur attal etc les personnels sont
méprisés par entendu c'est vrai dans les
écoles c'est vrai dans les collèges dans
les lycées
[Musique]
à vouloir laisser les écoles ouvertes
sans moyens humains supplémentaires sans
nous donner plus d'argent sans prendre
en compte le fait que c'est il ya une
fatigabilité de tout ça que c'est usant
qu' on est obligé des pistes explique à
un protocole tous les trois jours
différents à plein de parents on a
oublié d'envoyer des mails qu'on est
obligé de gérer des parents qui n'ont
des angoisses qui nous demandent des
explications en fait c'est tout ça
autour
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]